dans les jardins de port royal les
cuivres résonne pour la fête de la
musique
les familles se sont réunis dans les
jardins de l'abbaye pour célébrer cette
fête malgré les règles sanitaires à
respecter je crois qu'on a été privé
suffisamment longtemps de concert les
choses c'est une très bonne idée de
faire ça à l'extérieur
le fait de venir à la campagne s'asseoir
dans l'herbe ça fait du bien quand même
c'est quand même une liberté on retrouve
sa liberté de bah voilà de profiter des
bons moments et il la musique en est une
c'est formidable c'est c'est quand même
la base de beaucoup de choses la musique
j'en ai des confiné donc effectivement
on peut profiter en plus on est en plein
air donc pas de masse pas de rien on est
tranquille
les visiteurs ont pu déambuler tout en
appréciant les morceaux proposés par
l'ensemble couleur cuivre jouer à
nouveau ensemble depuis le confinement
il a fallu pour ce conte près en vente
et la musique pour pouvoir jouer en
extérieur
là ça va être une première pour nous de
jouer dehors j'espère que le temps va
tenir et
de façon à ce que ce soit festif pour
l'ouverture du musée pour le retour à la
musique au public surtout qui nous a
beaucoup manqué pendant quatre mois
on a dû continuer à s'entraîner et à
jouer et c'est jamais facile quand on
n'a pas de projections sur le long terme
et on est très très très content d'être
là aujourd'hui le musée port royal des
champs a profité de la fête de la
musique pour ouvrir ses portes qui a été
réaménagé à l'occasion pour maintenir la
distanciation physique
aujourd'hui ça reste compliqué de faire
des manifestations dans des endroits
fermés et confiné ce qui veut dire que
faire de la musique en plein air d'abord
c'est l'esprit de la fête de la musique
et que du coup les règles bien sûr
existent mais elles sont plus faciles à
observer c'est à dire que en jouant
dehors ou demande bien sûr au public de
garder les distances raisonnables de
faire effectivement attention mais on
n'a pas les contraintes d'une salle de
spectacle port royal des champs va
accueillir cet été des groupes et
orchestres pour permettre aux visiteurs
d'écouter de la musique en extérieur
tous les samedis soirs
[Musique]